people & daggers the
yurets went noise to the barn,
listen, you still
can’t get out of here alone,
so you either bosch or scare these
trees and valkyries, I remember,
but I didn’t shoot the civilian
population to your house, then
it’s those in the group gossip larch
as folders and  work of part of
you defeated space cadet class for some are
all the box permits therefore I have to
deliver this evidence to my command
or was published and released such put
those around brown sugar plum churicheva
today we are driving this any rights this
auto is sewn party  at recess
yuri sad
[music]
so still watching three
players backing up backing up perry graco hey mike
you're already in the place of the sniper
alyoshka also after the rooms instill
what you didn't understand there like a tanker truck mother
recipe views to you from the right to the right
wild I'll let you
solder yes  i don’t know how your free
feet where to the right
just in truth
write t shirt cheers cheers thomas plush
also my home molecule slide slide
admission slide
admission slide to reception through the leg of
the skyline answer I don’t think that it’s
just for the sake of with the spirits of the
forest
if this one threw on asked  how our
trick failed boris to boris’ house
where boris wears you your mother’s
welcome and you don’t happen to know where the former
hangs around here is a hobby
where we are nishtyachok and blood and deeds will run out
hear and nordic or maybe you can slow down the
locomotive to the sectarians what do you think
we will help out for you though  would compare
friends but didn’t decide to throw them there lari
knows maybe something went wrong
[music]
this is 2309
i came a man wanted to buy a
ticket from tarkov to the mainland
in exchange for your korea luggage
long before your boyfriend did
his ass  with a container, our Ministry of Defense has already
quietly blocked the
conversation, in just a day they turned it into a
fortress of a network lara, let my types
cool down, but after the evacuation of
civilians, the place of the riffraff also decided,
and the puddings of the approach
are bad to
remove any fish, but through everything
at home and the authorities of its regions and
finances
and foremother once again that one again
let's work let's
[ __ ] come on let's [ __ ] let's work
dry
[ __ ]
everything is now exactly
work
download maps behind these gates,
loading onto the ship is a
call, I can’t even believe that we
will soon talk about
where the leak for a year in the village is for me,
the currency
I am
.
I forgot something and stop and love to
break through tiu.ru
to swim
[applause]
now it’s completely already writing
but
I
have to.  says sit and
your
who
best way to locate try the
full meaning of the eyes
[music]
[applause] [
music] [
music]
[music]
I understood the composite
free
help jar such
[music]
literally a few hours ago
corresponding  he convened an emergency
meeting due to another aggravation in the
rabbinic area, but over the past 24 hours,
shots and explosions of artillery were heard in the area of ​​​​the place in the seaport,
this is the first case of the use of
heavy weapons in the blockaded
territories.
once again
assures the world community that the situation
is under complete control, however,
the command of the peacekeeping forces of one
present in the region are skeptical of
such
me
[music] [
music] [
music]
[applause] [
well
applause]
[music]
[music  ]
[applause]
[music]